WILL SQUEEZE IN SOME OTHER
IMPORTANT STORIES.
WILL FACT CHECK THOSE WHITE
SUPREMACY CLAIMS AND A LOOK
AHEAD TO TUESDAY’S DEBATE.
BUT FIRST I WANT TO LAY OUT
FOR YOU MY THOUGHTS ON THE
PRESIDENT’S RECOVERY, THE
MEDIA’S REACTION AND WHAT IT
ALL MEANS FOR THE ELECTION.
LET’S START WITH THE HUMAN
SIDE.
IT WAS GREAT TO SEE THE
PRESIDENTS VIDEO TONIGHT BUT
THE ONE I REALLY APPRECIATED
WAS LAST NIGHT AFTER ALL THE
MEDIA COVERAGE, THE WILD AND
HYSTERICAL SPECULATION.
IT WAS SUCH A RELIEF TO SEE
THE PRESIDENT’S MESSAGE.
THERE WAS ONE PART THAT REALLY
SHOWED HE’S BACK IN BUSINESS.
>> SHE IS HANDLING IT VERY
NICELY AS YOU’VE PROBABLY READ
SHE’S SLIGHTLY YOUNGER THAN
ME, JUST A LITTLE TINY BIT.
>> YEP, HE’S MAKING JOKES.
DEFINITELY A GOOD SIGN.
BUT IT’S ALL A SIGN OF
SOMETHING DEEPER TO PUT THE
PRESIDENT’S RECOVERY IS A
POWERFUL SYMBOL OF AMERICA’S
RECOVERY.
YES, HE GOT THE VIRUS BECAUSE
HE WAS OUT THERE FIGHTING FOR
THE FUTURE OF THE COUNTRY, NOT
HIDING IN A BASEMENT.
HE’S BEEN SAYING FOR MONTHS WE
NEED TO BE OPEN NOT RIGHT
WE’VE GOT TO BEAT THE VIRUS
NOT SURRENDER TO IT.
OF COURSE THAT HAS RISKS, BUT
THAT’S THE AMERICAN WAY, TO
TAKE RISKS SO YOU GET A BIGGER
REWARD AND WE ARE SEEING THAT
NOW WITH THE RECOVERY THAT IS
FASTER THAN EUROPE, STRONGER
THAN ANYONE WAS PREDICTING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A LIVING
SYMBOL OF THAT POSITIVE CAN-DO
SPIRIT.
PEOPLE ARE FREE TO DISAGREE,
BUT IT’S A CLEAR CONTRAST WITH
BIDEN.
IT GIVES VOTERS A CLEAR
CHOICE.
ANOTHER CONTRAST, THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN FIGHTING
FOR YEARS FOR BITER HEALTHCARE
THROUGH INNOVATION.
HE HAS THE RIGHT TO TRY
PRESIDENT.
HE WANTED AMERICANS TO HAVE
THE CHANCE TO TRY LIFE SAVINGS
NEW TREATMENT AND HE SWEPT
AWAY THE BUREAUCRACY THAT’S
STOOD IN THE WAY.
YOU SAW NATALIE AT THE
CONVENTION AND HERE ON THIS
SHOW SAYING SHE OWES HER LIFE
TO THAT.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP HIMSELF
PUTTING HIS OWN LIFE WHERE HIS
POLICY HAS BEEN TAKING
INNOVATIVE TREATMENT LIKE
REMDESIVIR AND REGENERON AND
SHOWING THEY WORK.
LET’S BE CLEAR, THE ONLY
REASON THESE ARE AVAILABLE IS
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP PUSHED
FOR THEM AGAINST THE
BUREAUCRACY AND THE STATUS QUO
THINKING OF THE SWAMP.
HE WANTS THEM AVAILABLE TO
EVERY AMERICAN.
THAT’S WHY HE’S BATTLING THE
FDA BUREAUCRATS OVER ALL
THIS.
HE IS A LIVING SYMBOL OF WHY
HE’S RIGHT AND RIGHT TO
FIGHT.
FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
TRUMP HATING ESTABLISHMENT
MEDIA, THE PRESIDENT IS NOW A
SYMBOL OF A DIFFERENT KIND.
WITHIN MINUTES OF HIM
ANNOUNCING HIS POSITIVE TEST
RESULTS THEY CAN BARELY
CONTAIN THEIR SMUG,
SATISFACTION.
>> IN LARGE PART, HIS OWN
DERELICTION IS PARTLY TO BLAME
FOR THIS.
>> CERTAINLY HIS RECKLESSNESS
HAS CONTRIBUTED TO HIS
HORRIBLE SITUATION.
>> HE HAS COME A TIME AND
AGAIN DENIED THE PANDEMIC,
SUGGESTED THAT IN THEIR BATTLE
OF THIS VIRUS, FLY IN THE FACE
OF SCIENCE AND BEEN WRONG OVER
AND OVER, AND NOW OF COURSE HE
HAS CONTRACTED IT AND THE
QUESTIONS ARE, WHAT COMES
NEXT?
>> THE NEXT DAY, DID YOU SEE
HOW THEY ALL WENT THROUGH THE
MOTIONS OF DECENCY BEFORE
GETTING TO WHAT THEY REALLY
WANTED TO DO, ATTACK A TRUMP
AND GLORY IN HIS MISFORTUNE.
>> IT’S VERY SAD BUT IT’S ALSO
SOMETHING THAT AGAIN, GOING
INTO CROWDS UNMASKED AND ALL
THE REST, THERE’S SORT OF A
BRAZEN INVITATION FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS TO
HAPPEN.
>> HER MESSAGE WAS NO
DIFFERENT TO THE CHINESE
REGIME.
THEY SAID THE PRESIDENT AND
THE FIRST LADY PAID THE PRICE
FOR PLAYING DOWN THE VIRUS.
NICE ALLIES YOU’VE GOT THERE
NANCY, THE DEMOCRATS TRIED TO
EXPLOIT THE SITUATION.
BIDEN SUDDENLY DECIDED HE
NEEDED TO WEAR A MASK WHILE HE
WAS SPEAKING.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO SAY
WE SHOULDN’T POLITICIZE MASK
WEARING.
SCHUMER WAS STRAIGHT OUT THE
GATE TRYING TO USE THIS TO
STOP AMY CALL ME BARRETT’S
CONFIRMATION AND MOST
LUDICROUSLY OF ALL, DERANGED
SENATOR CHRIS MURPHY I UTTERLY
EMBARRASSED HIMSELF WITH SOME
PREPOSTEROUS PLOT BUT NONE OF
IT IS AS BAD AS WHAT WE’VE
SEEN FROM THE MEDIA THESE LAST
FEW DAYS.
THEIR WHOLE REACTION HAS BEEN
ONE GIANT I TOLD YOU SO.
WE WERE RIGHT ALL ALONG THEY
CROW.
NOTHING CAPTURED THAT MORE
THAN THIS TODAY FROM BIDEN
AIDE MASQUERADING AS A
JOURNALIST JAKE TAPPER.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE
BECOME A SYMBOL OF YOUR OWN
FAILURES, FAILURES OF
RECKLESSNESS, IGNORANCE,
ARROGANCE, THE SAME FAILURES
YOU HAVE BEEN INFLICTING ON
THE REST OF US.
>> WE’VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
HERD IMMUNITY.
WHAT WERE SEEING NOW ON CNN
AND MSNBC AND THE NEW YORK
TIMES AND WASHINGTON POST AND
ALL THE REST OF THE
PROPAGANDIST IS HERD
STUPIDITY.
THEIR CENTRAL CLAIM IS THAT
TRUMP DIDN’T FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE.
REASONABLE, INTELLIGENT
THINKING PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
SCIENCE.
IT’S UNTHINKING IDEOLOGUE WHO
TALK ABOUT THE SCIENCE, TAPPER
AND TODD AND WALLACE AND ALL
THE OTHERS, THEY CLAIM IT HAS
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THE
VIRUS IS CUT AND DRIED.
THAT IS MISS INFORMATION.
SCIENTISTS ARE LEARNING NEW
THINGS ALL THE TIME AND
SCIENTISTS THEMSELVES
DISAGREE.
ORIGINALLY SCIENTISTS THOUGHT
THE VIRUS WAS CARRIED BY
DROPLETS THAT FALL UNDER THEIR
OWN WEIGHT NO FURTHER THAN OF
A FEW FEET AWAY.
THAT WAS THE BASIS FOR THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING 6 FEET AWAY
RULE BUT NOW THEY SAY IT
TRAVELS THROUGH THE AIR IN
AEROSOLS AND CAN TRAVEL UP TO
30 FEET AND HANG AROUND FOR
HOURS SO THE MOST USEFUL THING
RIGHT NOW MIGHT BE TO
ENCOURAGE THE WIDE USE OF AIR
FILTRATION SYSTEMS KNOWN AS
HIPAA FILTERS THAT BLOCK VIRUS
TRANSMISSION.
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES SUPPORT THE
USE OF AND 95 MASKS AS A
PROTECTION AGAINST THE VIRUS.
MANY SCIENTIFIC STUDIES SAY
CLOTH MASKS DON’T STOP VIRUS
PARTICLES.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
LIKE DOCTOR 5G AND THE CDC
ORIGINALLY TOLD US NOT TO WEAR
MASKS BUT EVEN WHEN THEY
CHANGE THEIR MIND, THEY DIDN’T
ACTUALLY PRETEND THAT MASKS
STOPPED THE VIRUS.
THE WHO SAID MASKS SHOULD BE
THREE LAYERS AND EVEN WITH
THOSE, THE USE OF A MASK ALONE
IS INSUFFICIENT TO PROVIDE AN
ADEQUATE LEVEL OF PROTECTION
OR SOURCE CONTROL.
LISTEN TO THE REASONS I GAVE
WERE WEARING MASKS.
REDUCING STIGMATIZATION,
MAKING PEOPLE FEEL INCLUDED.
MOST OF THE REASONS WEREN’T
EVEN MEDICAL.
IN ANY CASE THE DATA DOESN’T
SUPPORT WHAT THE MEDIA ARE
SAYING.
IF YOU LISTEN TO THEM THE LAST
FEW DAYS PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
BEEN PRACTICALLY RUNNING
AROUND THE COUNTRY RIPPING
PEOPLE’S MASKS OFF THERE FACES
AND WHERE THE MOST MASK LISTS
ENTRY.
WERE MUCH HIGHER.
[INAUDIBLE]
IT’S THE SAME IDEOLOGICAL
PSEUDOSCIENCE WAS SHUT DOWN.
ANYONE WHO DARE SUGGEST
OPENING THINGS UP IS BRANDED A
MURDERER BUT MORE EVIDENCE IS
ACCUMULATING THAT THE SHUTDOWN
DID MORE HARM THAN GOOD.
LITTLE EFFECT ON THE VIRUS BUT
MASSIVE HEALTH, AND SOCIAL
ECONOMIC COSTS.
THE ESTABLISHMENT MEDIA WON’T
EVEN ALLOW THIS TO BE SAID.
THEY GO ON AND ON ABOUT
CONTACT TRACING BUT THE LATEST
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT THE
WHOLE PREMISE OF THE CURRENT
CONTACT TRACING APPROACHES
FLAWED.
AS I SAID HERE AN OLD PLAYBOOK
FOR A DIFFERENT DISEASE.
WERE LEARNING THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN
SPREADING THE DISEASE.
[INAUDIBLE]
TRADING TRACING THEIR CONTACT
IS A WASTE OF TIME AND
RESOURCES.
JAKE TAPPER ACCUSED HIM HAVE
ARROGANCE BUT WHEN HE SPOUTS
OFF ABOUT THE SCIENCE HE’S THE
ONE DISPLAYING IGNORANCE.
I WANT TO READ TO YOU THE
WORDS OF AN ACTUAL SCIENTISTS,
AND INFECTIOUS DISEASE
PROFESSOR ON THE UK EQUIVALENT
OF THE CORONAVIRUS TAX FORCE.
BOTH THE VIRUS AND THE WAY
THEY’RE TACKLING IT BECAUSE
HARM AND NEED TO BE BALANCED.
WHY SCIENTISTS CAN ENSURE THAT
ANY STRATEGIES ARE UNDERPINNED
BY THE BUS RESEARCH, THEY
SHOULD HAVE NO GREATER SAY IN
THEM THAN ECONOMISTS,
HISTORIANS AND THE WIDER
PUBLIC.
JUST AS IN SOCIETY AT LARGE
THERE ARE SOME SCIENTISTS WHO
THINK THE CURE IS WORTH WORSE
THAN THE DISEASE.
THIS IS NOW ESSENTIAL CHOICE
IN THE ELECTION.
POLICY SHOULD BE INFORMED BY
SCIENTISTS, NOT RUN BY
SCIENTISTS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP LISTENS TO THE
SCIENTISTS AND THEN LEAVES.
JOE BIDEN IS LED BY THEM.
HE TOLD US THAT.
I’LL SHUT IT DOWN HE SAID, ALL
THE PUNDITS ARE SAYING THAT
THIS EPISODE IS A DISASTER FOR
TRUMP BECAUSE IT WILL FOCUS
ATTENTION ON CORONAVIRUS
INSTEAD OF THE ECONOMY.
THAT COULD JUST BE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF HERD STUPIDITY.
IF THE PRESIDENT’S RECOVERY
CONTINUES, IF HE SHOWS A NEW
MORE POSITIVE AND MORE HUMAN
SIDE AS HE HAD BEEN DOING THIS
WEEKEND AND LEAVE THE ATTACKS
ON BIDEN TO HIS CIRCUITS, HE
WILL FOCUS HIS ATTENTION ON
WHAT EVERYONE WANTS TO SEE,
RECOVERY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S RECOVERY
ACHIEVED IN NO SMALL PART
BECAUSE OF THE ACTIONS HE TOOK
TO GET NEW TREATMENTS
AVAILABLE AS A LIVING SYMBOL
OF AMERICA’S RECOVERY, A
MASSIVE CONTRAST WITH THE WEEK
DEFEATISM OF JOE BIDEN AND HIS
THREAT OF ANOTHER SHUTDOWN.